uh but we're going to begin with the
news as we always do and the debate over
what's at stake in Tuesday's midterms as
many GOP candidates refuse to promise
that they will accept the results of the
election if they lose last night in a
speech at Washington's Union Station
President Biden argued that democracy
itself is at risk
we the people must decide whether the
rule of law Prevail or there will allow
the dark Forces
to search that thirst for power
put ahead of the principles that we've
long guided us
former president Barack Obama had a
similar message at a rally in Arizona
but our polling shows that right now the
economy is the number one issue for
voters amid worries about high inflation
Chris Van Cleave has made his way to
Tempe Arizona for us this morning Chris
good morning
good morning inflation here in the
Phoenix Metro area has grown at the
highest rate in the country over the
last year so the economy is on every
voter's Minds Republicans are putting
the economy border security and crime at
the center of their message to voters
Democrats including President Obama are
arguing that democracy itself is at
stake
I'm fired up former president Barack
Obama laid out Wednesday night what's at
stake for arizonans come election day
one
clear and that is this this increasing
habit
of demonizing political opponents so I
get why people are anxious but Phoenix I
am here to tell you
that tuning out is not an option
rallying support for Democrats including
Secretary of State Katie Hobbs who is in
a deadlocked race with Republican
candidate Carrie Lake for governor turns
out being president or governor is about
more than Snappy lines and good lighting
I don't think anybody I mean Elvis could
come back to life and campaign for Katie
Hops and it wouldn't help her Lake a
former longtime TV news anchor has
embraced former president Donald Trump's
false accusations about the 2020
election we are going to restore Faith
honesty and integrity in our elections
in Arizona
interesting that Barack Obama is here in
town today to rally for Katie Hobbs and
Mark Kelly I think they're hoping that
the former president can reinvigorate
their flailing campaigns Republican
Senate candidate Blake Masters has also
raised doubts about the 2020 election
results he's hoping for a come from
behind win against Democrat incumbent
Senator Mark Kelly
families are struggling
with the high cost of gas groceries and
housing the economy is largely driving
Republicans like Roy Nielsen the last
two years have been a disaster in so
many ways and we know that I mean
disaster from economy from my 401k but
former lifelong Republican Monica
Villalobos is voting Democrat this year
what changed everything everything
changed and some of those tactics that
are being proposed by the Republican
Party hurt business and they hurt the
brand of Arizona
the sense is that all of the races here
in Arizona are very very close a federal
judge has issued an order aimed at
halting reports of voter suppression
prohibiting armed at people people
wearing body armor from monitoring
ballot drop boxes here in Arizona the
tensions around the vote itself remain
very high Gale
all right Chris thank you very much